the Joe Rogan experience you're gonna be
intertwined with this thing
[ __ ] yeah you're talking about that app
about the tracking the Cova tracking the
DA which is just it sounds scary to me
get the [ __ ]
that's an NSA [ __ ] that's really scary
they're gonna keep going this is what
things do they like if it's your job to
try to do something like this to try to
implement something we can get people to
agree to tracking if it's your job to do
that you're gonna keep going yes once
you get that tracking then you're gonna
want some new [ __ ] then you want cameras
in front of people's houses see if they
really are quarantine and you know
they're doing that in China yes this guy
just got back from a trip in China they
gave him a 14-day quarantine and they
put a [ __ ] camera right in front of
his door that's weird
he's like whoa like you're not going
anywhere for 14 days and we're watching
you it's also strange for people in
politics to encourage society to snitch
on people that's weird that's a level of
tracking you know don't you think that's
[ __ ] weird and wrong it's weird and
wrong but it's even worse if you're
offering rewards that's you're saying if
you're saying usually snitches get
stitches but this guys are gonna get
riches you know what it is Joe honestly
it's it's it's a behavior change
it's a weird step towards this tracking
system that's going to be implemented
that right they're starting to be like
oh it's okay we're going to reinforce
you guys being stitches it's it snitches
it's fine here's a little treat for you
here's 500 bucks for letting me know
that Karen was out not doing the proper
protocol meanwhile there have been that
many deaths like relatively to what they
thought they were going to be and so
that means this is a success so that
means the way it's being implemented so
far has been a success like you're
getting it more aggressive with it even
though the laws are way lower than we
thought they were going to be what are
we doing George we're doing the right
thing I understand that it's hard for
people if just you know keep an eye on
each other don't let people do stupid
[ __ ] you shouldn't have [ __ ] parties
but you also shouldn't give people
rewards to snitch no that's not a house
party the other day were people that
matter
son someone put it up on their Instagram
I'm like he's the best instrument so
good it's so good and he posts all day
long he's just the funniest [ __ ] he
really does a house party was packed
yeah it was a packed house party I think
it said something like if these people
ain't dead in 14 days I'm gonna go out
people are partying with masks on
they're partying in my apartment as well
like not my where I personally go with
the building people have been having
house parties having them chillin I hear
there's cards against humanity'
happening a lot oh my god
it's wild and like you see the beach
don't nobody from this house partied I'm
14 days I'm going outside and also why
is it so bright
well it looks more like a meeting that
just let out and in it in a business
maybe this is [ __ ] that's the thing
well maybe someone turned the lights on
and take a picture how do we know these
photos so many photos are doctored like
you talked about the the picture from
the the beach how do we even know what
date that's from I'm sure a lot of these
things you can sort of track but then
they posted a picture about you know the
state the anti stay home protesters it
was a photo from like an election from
2011 one thing I saw
[Applause]